the reopening of schools as school
districts across the country debate how
to safely get kids back in the classroom
this fall
arkansas is giving them the green light
to return to in-person learning later
this month arkansas governor asa
hutchinson joins us now
to discuss governor thanks so much for
being here why did you make this call
for five
day a week in person school
well the school environment is so
important for our young people
you can't have the same level of
education
you can't have the same consistency
without the in classroom instruction
and it's very challenging because
teachers want to make sure it's safe as
they go back
uh you want to make sure that uh the
students
take the precautions they're gonna have
to wear masks we're gonna have to do
social distancing
which they're not accustomed to and so
we've got a lot of work to do in
arkansas
but we've got a couple weeks still left
before we actually start
our in classroom instruction but we're
committed to that that's very important
for us we know it's going to be
challenging
but it just makes all the difference in
world for the young people
and that includes the the sports side of
things that
is an important part of their life as
well it's not like they're either going
to be in sports or they're going to be
in their
bedroom they're going to be somewhere in
the community
this is a more structured environment we
ought to be able to accomplish that as
well
in a safe way governor speaking of
opening doors
you and arkansas are opening the door to
the nra as new york tries to
dissolve them with that new lawsuit why
should they move
to arkansas well this is a very
startling
attack and a coordinated attack from the
left
on an organization that defends the
second amendment
you've got both the lawsuit in the
district of columbia against the
foundation
you've got the attack in new york by the
attorney general against the nra
it doesn't take anyone that's
too astute to observe that they're
simply trying to destroy
an organization that supports the second
amendment
and whether you're a firearm
manufacturer an ammunition manufacturer
or you're an organization that supports
the second amendment
if you're in a state that doesn't
appreciate that and value that
come south come to arkansas we value the
second amendment
and we understand the nra is not perfect
and if there's accountability issues
there
they ought to pursue those but don't
destroy an organization
because it supports the second amendment
that's exactly right governor and what's
so telling as well in addition to the
timing
of this lawsuit by the new york attorney
general right the
allegations go back at least three years
and certainly this investigation has
been
ongoing for quite some time so the
revelation of such is pretty telling
given it's an election year and
about 87 days beforehand but also the
fact that
the what they're seeking is complete
dissolution when the allegations are for
corporate fraud in the part of just
redirecting finances right so it's sort
of a
an incredible remedy that they are
seeking an incredible
solution to something that we don't
usually actually see in law
it's so important for the public to
understand that you've got to
distinguish between
an action that says we want to make sure
that there's an audit that money is
being spent appropriately
that's fairly routine and appropriate
to examine but to take it to that second
level and say
we want to dissolve a legitimate
organization that has served for decades
citizens that simply believe in the
second amendment
that is taking legal power and abusing
it and that's what the attorney general
has done
with this coordinated attack it is
political
it is something that is designed for the
election that's coming up
you said arkansas would be a natural
home for the nra we will see governor
hutchinson
thank you so much for your time this
morning